c'était en 1976 du haut de ses 5 153
mètres la tour cn devenait la plus haute
en son genre au monde
elle accueillait ses premiers visiteurs
quarante deux ans plus tard la tour se
veut plus moderne avec de nouveaux
panneaux de verre du plancher au plafond
qui agrémentent l'expérience est
impressionnant ça fait un peu comme moi
j'ai une formation un peu d'étouffement
de francs j'ai le vertige donc été très
impressionnant j'avais à tâtons sur la
vitre mais pas pas plus vite que ça le
concept doit plaire aussi à ceux qui se
déplace en chaise roulante et qui n'ont
pas peur des hauteurs trois nouveaux
bistrots met l'accent sur les produits
locaux
ils viennent remplacer un restaurant
avec service aux tables
un concept pensé en fonction du public
d'aujourd'hui et qui dit modernisation
dix nouvelles technologies la tour cn
lance en même temps cette nouvelle
application une obligation en temps réel
qui répond à la question de plusieurs
visiteurs qui se trouve devant moi la
société d'état qui gère la tour cn a
dépensé 16 millions de dollars pour en
arriver là dit qu'elle ne compte pas
augmenter le prix des billets qui
s'élève déjà à 38 $ pour les adultes
l'an passé près de deux millions de
personnes ont visité la tour cn gestion
les visiteurs ne manquent pas mais il
faut toujours leur apporter quelque
chose alors apporte quelque chose de
nouveau et à l'hacienda heures même si
elle est seule la seule grande tour bien
évidemment à toronto fait concurrence à
d'autres icônes qui est dans le monde et
donc il faut toujours être à la
recherche d'une amélioration du service
un service qui en vaut la peine selon
cette touriste en visite de paris des
coûts
la ville en hauteur qu'on voit pas du
tout quand on est au sol on se rend
compte aussi que la skyline est très
diversifiée une ville diversifié qui a
changé d'alluré au fil du temps mais
dont la silhouette demeure marqué par
cette icône ici m caron radio canada
toronto